we're joined by the former chief
executive of Sainsbury's Justin King
good morning Justin
good morning Trevor and I'm one of those
over 60s too so it's uh yeah
yeah I'll I'll see you down there
um look we're saying Supermarket it's
taking
these actions special deals explicitly
aimed uh at people to help people in
tough economic circumstances
um
one as the I think it is providing warm
spaces for people
do you support all of that
well I've worked for Asda Sainsbury's
I'm a director of Marks and Spencers now
and uh it's been my working life so yes
I do I think supermarkets have always
taken very seriously the role that they
play in helping their customers if you
like make ends meet and the challenge
hasn't been as great as this until uh
well since you and I were a lot younger
I can remember the 1970s which is
probably the last time the challenges
households were as great
um and they will play what part they can
you have to remember of course at
supermarkets typically make uh only
about three percent profit so you know
even if they invested say half of their
potential profits in this kind of
activity it's only going to make a small
dent but an important dent I would
suggest on the challenges of you know
nearly 10 inflation that you've just
been discussing
but I I suppose a question that will
occur to many people is whether this is
really a supermarket business let me put
it uh This Way
um
the big shareholders in most British
supermarkets uh chains are also for
example Pension funds and they expect a
return is it really right for
supermarkets to be doing a job that
really is for the Social Services uh and
endangering the returns uh for
pensioners
well I said they're playing their part
and of course what they're really doing
is competing they're fighting for
customers you know when times are
challenging uh customers do shop around
a bit more so
um if you wanted to be cynical of course
you could say that these are just
marketing activities aimed at capturing
new customers so I don't see any kind of
logical disconnect if you like between
this kind of activity and supermarkets
doing the right thing for their
shareholders too of course only uh two
of our supermarkets are now uh publicly
listed companies the big ones uh anyway
Sainsbury's and Tesco others are
privately held or held by uh big
worldwide chains
um I frankly don't think you should
worry too much and any customers to
worry too much about shareholders being
looked after that's the job of
management along with making sure they
do a great job for customers because in
the long run the right thing for
shareholders is doing the right thing
for customers
okay well I I suppose that I read the
the earlier this week that um waitrose
has its thermal underwear flying off the
shelves and uh I suppose some people
might wonder whether the real answer
here is for supermarkets to be pricing
their uh normal Goods even more
competitively because that will help a
wider range of people rather than what
to some people might look like a bit of
a gimmick
well as I said you know the cynical
might say it's just a marketing activity
but it doesn't mean it's a bad thing to
do uh yes of course across the piece
they'll need to keep their prices sharp
if you're not competitive on price at
the moment and more and more customers
are focusing on price then you're going
to be in trouble competitively so I
think they'll be doing that too but as I
said that earlier you know they haven't
got massive profit percentages they can
make a dent uh uh in the inflation that
customers will experience on their
grocery shop and you mentioned waitrose
and thermals a battle Being John Lewis
and of course marks and Spencer has a
big clothing business to keeping clothes
competitive particularly those we use to
wrap up warm as we enter winter that'll
be part of the competition too
is there a danger here though I mean
this is all this all sounds weather it's
marketing gimmick or not it's going to
benefit some people I don't think
anybody will object to that but there is
a danger that What's Happening Here is
that the government gets uh LED off the
hook uh because next week a minister
will come in here and say to Sophie
honestly you know don't expect us to do
too much uh and everybody's pitching in
look at what the supermarket's doing
they're helping
well I have a chat with Sophie and tell
her not to let them off that hook
obviously everyone should play their
part and supermarkets will do because
it's a competitive market but you spend
most of this program discussing one way
or another uh what difference the
government can make uh we've seen on
Energy prices a very significant and
costly uh support package but we should
remember every single pound the
government spends is our money still
we'll have to pay it back through taxes
or perhaps more likely our children and
grandchildren will be paying it back
through taxes so I don't think either we
should be uh overly blase about the
amount of money the government's
spending personally I think it should be
more targeted and less blanket I think
those of us that can afford and I'm very
fortunate to be one of those people to
pay my bills for the energy even at
these high levels I think we should pay
off all bills and that would leave more
money for the most needing and I
personally believe
um much government activity would be
better if it were targeted
does that mean um I mean you you've been
in charge of some of the biggest
Enterprises in this country with
millions of consumers and so on uh so
you do follow their behaviors pretty
closely
um
from that point of view do you think
that what the chancellor did and the way
he approached the issue of dealing with
cost of living
um was essentially the wrong approach
from what you've just said about
targeting it suggests that you think
that uh
they could have done better
well look the I think we now officially
call it a mini uh budget was uh argued
to be necessary because the issues that
addressed were urgent and some of those
issues uh fuel prices for winter were
clearly urgent but others of the issues
some of the tax changes you've been
discussing were not urgent and I think
that's as much as anything is what uh
spurred the markets with the
consequences that it's going to have for
people's household budgets with
inflation and interest rates of course
um but yes as a general rule I don't
think the government should be giving
money to those uh people who can afford
to pay their bills so it can give more
money to those who are going to struggle
I think targeting is perfectly possible
initially through the benefit system but
through some kinds of means testing and
I also they should think there should be
a limit to the help the government
provides um you know long before this
cost of living crisis arrived we were
discussing uh the carbon crisis and a
higher energy prices higher fuel prices
we're all driving our cars less because
of how expensive petrol and Diesel is
that's a good thing if you take the Long
View it may be painful to household
budgets in the short term but we have to
have a different relationship with
energy we as a society so I I would not
provide an unlimited support I would
make sure that everyone's able to keep
themselves warm and fed But ultimately
we have to pay a higher price for Energy
going forward
admirably clear as always Justin thanks
very much for joining us this this
morning
thank you